another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the scp foundation dr bright is  not allowed to declare war on any  country thing or person look jack we  told you that you couldn't take over the  bodies of any monarchs or presidents but  you should also know that that also  implicitly covered high-ranking generals  and dictators of military juntas the  foundation doesn't want you to declare  wars on anything even symbolic wars like  the time you declared war on stress  during efforts to lower the collective  office blood pressure of site 19. let's  just try to avoid using such militarily  loaded language in the future okay